further now with Miles B kagin III who's
a retired colonel in the US Army who
served in the Pentagon and National
Security Council he was also spokesman
for the global coalition to defeat isil
in Iraq and Syria and is joining us on
Al jazer from Rebel in Northern Iraq
Colonel thank you so much for speaking
to us as we heard our correspondent say
there no damage assessment yet from St
sencom what do you know and what do you
think could have targeted could have
been targeted here by by the US these 85
Targets in Syria and Iraq what type of
damage was inflicted where were these
high value targets for these armed
groups these attacks by the United
States on katab Hezbollah and Iranian
back militia groups had two primary
purposes one was information sending a
message to reassure Americans that we
take it seriously when Iran attacks
attacks and kills our troops and also to
send a message to the militias in Iran
that we too the United States can reach
out and strike anywhere we choose at any
time of our choosing now from the
attacks on seven different locations and
85 different targets as has been uh
released by The centcom and and the
White House it's clear that this was an
operation to destroy storage facilities
for rockets and drones to and to ALS
eliminate some of the command and
control but how significant were these
locations
though the significance of these
locations is that they were in an area
where uh katab Hezbollah has had
complete freedom of movement back and
forth across the border at the alheim uh
location there's a federal Iraq border
crossing a a a recognized border
crossing and then there is a militia
controlled border crossing where lethal
Aid drug
other Contraband and terrorist Fighters
flow back and forth freely the reason I
asked about the significance of the
location is because the strikes had been
expected for several days now and there
are many questions about the timing and
forcefulness of the US response because
Biden's critics have said it could have
allowed these armed groups to withdraw
their assets and Personnel before the
strikes uh President Biden's critics
have said it took too long and it to
took too long for the US to respond so
again what what is the impact of these
strikes really if these militias could
have had time to withdraw from these
positions well I know this from my
experience that America is always
watching the militias we have ways to
observe them from space from the air and
using signals intercepts and
occasionally sources on the ground uh
the militias cannot hide from American
Air power and the timing of the strikes
uh was designed for purposes of of
planning targets that were agreed
through through the National Security
Council process what is important is
that the Secretary of Defense has
signaled that this is just the beginning
of a campaign of strikes and I
anticipate that if Iranian militias
attack again America will respond
quickly and
forcefully uh I will ask you in a moment
about whether this could lead to a wider
conflict but just coming back to the
impact do you you really think that this
response will reestablish deterrence uh
for for of these
groups Iran has sent its proxies
throughout the Middle East for more than
two decades it is unlikely that they
will be deterred with their ultimate
goals uh however in the short run they
have had some quick behavioral changes
but one thing that you can trust from
terrorist groups is that they will
commit to their ideals and they will
continue to make attacks at the time and
place of their choosing and it's
important for America and its Partners
including the Iraqi security forces and
peshmerga to stand up and resist these
unlawful militias operating inside of
Iraq you the the resp you'd mention Iran
but the response we've heard from Iran
so far has been somewhat of a low-key
one a muted one because it's clear that
they don't want to escalate this war so
I mean where where is the US taking this
now President Biden says he doesn't want
to turn uh this into a wider regional
conflict but by launching these strikes
does it not do
that the wider regional conflict is
already under way your network has
reported extensively about the Israeli
War on Gaza and the uh who these attacks
on shipping and now we have this back
and forth between Iran and the USA in
Iraq and Syria so all leaders have said
that they are wanting to deescalate and
not have a wider war that remains to be
seen because they're responsive to their
critics they're responsive to their
populations and they have a
responsibility to protect their people
and their interest and in this case it
has led to air strikes rocket attacks
and drone attacks all right Colonel
thank you so much for talking to us
thank you for your time miles B kagan's
the third a retired col in the US Army
joining us from herel in Northern
Iraq